son would be Avenged
Whispers slithered through the taverns
and back alleys of flea bottom two men
were found
one was a former gold cloak the other a
rat catcher in the red keep who knew all
its secrets
history remembers them only as blood and
cheese
one night Queen Helena entered the Royal
apartments with her daughter and two
sons to put them to bed without warning
blood and cheese bursting daggers in
hand they told her that a debt was owed
a son for a son blood and cheese
demanded she choose which Sun would be
ripped from her forever
Queen Elena pleaded with the man to kill
her instead but they refused weeping
Helena named her younger son Malo
perhaps she thought the boy was too
young to understand
perhaps because the older boy was King
aegon's first-born son and Heir you hear
that little boy she's whispered to the
younger son your mama wants you dead
then blood struck off the older boy's
head with a single blow when the gods
burst in they found Queen Helena still
screaming clasping her dead son's body
to her mad with grief
the blood of their children transformed
a dynastic dispute into a war of
annihilation you have to wait two years
until the next episode of House of the
Dragon so now is the perfect time for
you to listen to the audiobook on which
house of the Dragon is based and you can
listen to it now for free that's right
you can listen to Fire and Blood
audiobook for free it's a Targaryen
history book on which house of the
Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
our link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
the grief and rage of losing a child
could burn down the world
either aegon or anira could live at the
end but not both
rhaenyra's forces struck yet another
blow the moment the Lord of harrenhal
Saw Damon Targaryen circling the castle
on his Dragon caresses he struck his
banners and surrendered the blanks now
had the strongest castle in the
riverlands dark a new still came to
aegon thanks to rhaenyra's Sons
Winterfell had declared for rhaenyra as
had the Veil Furious aegon dismissed his
grandfather so Otto was hand and
appointed sir Kristen Cole who swore to
march on all the Lords who had declared
for rhaenyra and put their castles to
the torch
coal and the Royal Army first marched
North and laid Siege to rook's rest a
black stronghold near Dragonstone when
their lord saw their approach he sent a
raven to rhaenyra begging for help
for days he watched his fields and
Villages burning with no response from
his Queen
the one day a shadow passed over the
green army rhaenyra had sent not an army
but her former Mother by Laura rames and
her dragon melees as her ancestor had
done at the Field of Fire rhaenys
gleefully began to incinerate sir
Christian's Army but aegon had set a
trap at rhaenys had flown right into it
as rhaenys and melees blanketed sir
Christian's troops and dragonflame two
other dragons Rose into the sky
Eamonn on Vega and King aegon himself on
the gleaming Sunfire to her credit rainy
didn't flee Dragon fought dragons and
his second son blossomed in the sky
When the Smoke cleared only aymond and
Vega stood uninjured Sunfire the most
magnificent dragon in the world had one
of its wings almost completely torn from
its body
trapped beneath Sunfire was the king
himself broken and burned so badly in
places that his armor had fused onto his
flesh his body survived but his mind was
given over to Milk of the poppy melees
had been torn to shreds and her rider
rhaenys was a pile of Ash
panicked by the defeat rhaenyra shipped
her two youngest sons across the narrow
sea for their protection
only for her youngest to return Days
Later clinging to the neck of his
wounded and dying Dragon he and his
brother had been set upon by an enemy
Fleet just off Dragonstone
defying his mother's command reinira's
eldest son in Heir jacaris mounted his
Dragon Vermax and flew to rescue his
other brother and punish the enemy Fleet
but the Foolish Boy let Vermax be hooked
like a trout and dragged into the sea
where he soaked up even more arrows and
seawater
brother disappeared over the horizon or
beneath the waves no one could say for
sure
with the loss of four dragons rhaenyra's
only Advantage was fading luckily for
her over the centuries House Targaryen
had spilled more than blood on
Dragonstone
she promised gold and title to any of
the Targaryen bastards who could tame
the six unclaimed dragons on the island
these bastards were called the dragon
seeds though most were called supper and
perhaps the Dragons Were eventually
sated or bored but four of them accepted
Riders and were enlisted in rhaenyra's
cause
after rook's rest Eamonn one eye took
command of the greens from his crippled
and Poppy adult brother Eamonn was the
blood of the dragon and Dragonstone
cower behind City walls he marched the
king's Army North to take back harrenhal
from rhaenyra's husband Damon
but when he and Kristen Cole reach the
castle they found the gates open with
Damon and all his men gone
that night they feasted their Victory
Damon had fled rather than face their
Wrath
the Damon was more Snake than dragon as
Eamonn marched North he'd flown karaxi's
South slithering past the green army
over the Waters of the God's eye
one day King's Landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul City
Damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne for the city was defenseless
Eamonn had taken the king's Army from
the city and worse he'd taken his Dragon
Vega
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small Council surrendered the city the
Queen Mother Alison and the broken Queen
Helena
but not King aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city
and so Queen rhaenira climbed the steps
and seated herself on the Iron Throne
Legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hands proving the Iron Throne had
spurned her nonsense
it's a chair made of steel blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
had sacrificed two sons for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight
when Eamonn realized that his arrogance
had cost him the capital he mounted
vagar in a black rage and rained fire
onto every village and Castle he
suspected of disloyalty abandoned by
Eamonn to Kristen marched the Royal Army
back to King's Landing intent on
recapturing the city himself instead he
was trapped and cut to Pieces by The
riverlords Who had sworn to support
rhaenyra's claim when a new Army of
green loyalists marched up from the
reach and laid Siege to the city of
tumbleton rhaenyra sent two of her
Dragon Siege to lay waste to them
instead the dragon seeds proved their
bastard nature and betrayed her they
burned the city and all the black forces
garrisoned Within
lucky for her they didn't turn towards
King's Landing but hauled and drank in
the ruins with the greens who were
victorious
and somewhat confused
Rainier now mistrusted all the dragon
seeds including the girl who rode with
her husband Damon hunting Eamonn in the
riverlands
she ordered the girl's head be sent to
her but there was a complication as well
as her Dragon the girl had taken to
writing Daemon
when Damon received the Queen's order
he proclaimed that a queen's words and a
[ __ ] work he sent the girl away a
Dawn watching her and her Dragon vanish
into the morning Mists then Damon sent
the challenge to his nephew eamond and
flew to Heron Hall alone
to wait
14 days later the shadow blacker than
any passing clouds swept over herrenhaal
Veigar had come at last and on her back
rode one-eyed Prince Eamonn he mocked
Damon for facing him alone you have
lived too long uncle and Damon replied
on that much we agree then the old
Prince climbed stiffly onto the back of
his dragon caraxis
but neglected to fasten the chains that
secured Rider in Tucson
the sun was close to setting when as one
the two dragons leapt into the sky Damon
took her axis up swiftly until they
disappeared into a bank of clouds vegar
older and slow ascended more gradually
up and up vegar sword searching for
karatsis
sudden as a thunderbolt a shrieking
karaxi's Dove upon vagar locked together
the dragon stumbled toward the lake
karaxi's Jaws closed about vegar's neck
but Vega raked open karaxi's belly and
her teeth ripped off a wing
the lake rushed up with terrible speed
then Damon Targaryen who had never
fastened his writing chains stood in his
saddle he leapt from his Dragon to
eamonn's and in his hand was dark since
the Valyrian sword of aegon's sister
Queen visenya
as aemond one eye looked up in Terror
Damon ripped off his nephew's Helm and
drove the sword down into his one
remaining eye so hard the point came out
the back of the young princess throat
a heartbeat later the dragons struck the
lake sending up a gout of water so high
that it was said to have been as tall as
harrenhal's great tower
the lake boiled with dragon blood
and then was still
Damon Targaryen was 9 and 40 at his
death Prince aymond had only turned 20.
vegar the greatest of the Targaryen
dragons had counted
181 years
thus past the last living creature from
the days of aegon's Conquest
back in King's Landing Queen rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her
stupid husband the Mad former Queen
Helena flung herself From a Balcony to
be impaled upon the iron spikes lining
them out of maegor's holdfast
that night the city Rose in Riot against
rhaenyra demanding Justice for Queen
Helena and her murdered son among other
foolish peasant fantasies
in the midst of this chaos a one-handed
fool called a Shepherd began to rant
against dragons not just the ones of the
enemy but all dragons everywhere as he
pointed at the dragon pit above on the
hill he shouted they're the demons dwell
this is their city if you would make it
yours first You Must Destroy them
cry went up from ten thousand throats
kill them
there were four dragons housed within
the dragon pit that night by the time
the first of the attackers came pouring
in all four were roused awake and angry
nobody knows how many men and women died
that night who cares they all should
have trapped within the pit the dragons
could not fly instead they fought with
horns claws teeth and fire for every man
who died ten more appeared shouting that
the dragons must die one by one they did
finally the last remaining Dragon broke
her chain spread her wings and flew
straight up at the great Dome trying to
flee already weakened by dragonflame the
Dome cracked under the force of impact
and then tumbled down crushing Dragon
Slayers and herself
High Atop The Red keep Queen rhaenyra
clutched her two remaining Sons to her
as she watched the end of a family's
might too afraid of the peasants to
defend her dragons at least her older
son Joffrey had a man's spine he stole
his mother's Dragon Cyrax and tried to
fly it to the dragon pit to save his
Birthright
the stupid Beast didn't understand and
twisted beneath him fighting to be free
of the little boy
until it was
a queen is still a woman with all the
weakness of that sex
weeping for her lost son more than her
dragons rhaenyra abandoned the iron
throne and sold her crown to buy passage
for her and her last son back to
Dragonstone
rhaenyra hoped to hatch more dragons
from the eggs in the castle
but when she landed the welcoming party
slew her guards and marched her and her
son at spear point to the castle to face
a dead man and a dying dragon
sister King aegon second of his name
called out to rhaenera rook's rest had
left aegon bent and twisted his once
handsome face puffy from milk of the
poppy with burn scars covering half his
body rhaenyra ever defiant told her dear
brother that she'd hoped he was dead
after you aegon answered
then Sunfire
bathed her in a blast of flame
devoured her in six bites when the sun
watched leaving the seventh and final
bite her lower leg
for The Stranger
rhaenyra was dead and King aegon sat the
Iron Throne again
but only for half a year
he was poisoned by his own men and
replaced with the very boy who had
watched his mother devoured
when rhaenerys lost on wet aegon's only
daughter the dance of dragons officially
ended
passion burned men all that was left of
the revelance
two scared children spouting Oaths they
didn't understand
all that was left of the mighty House
Targaryen
ancient skulls and hatchlings
That Grew no bigger than cats all that
was left of the dragons
two years until season two is a long
period but you can still stay in the
house of the Dragon World by listening
to Fire and Blood audiobook for free
house of the Dragon is based on Fire and
Blood book and covers the entire
Targaryen history starting from aegon
the Conqueror and his Conquest as well
as megur the cruel and other legendary
targaryens including the current and
future events of House of the Dragon go
and listen to it for free with horrible
trial using our Link in the description
foreign